hey everyone it's mike from overflows
and in this video i'm going to show you
how to set up the order flows sequencing
tool in markers from the indicator store
you know markers is a great tool for
automating your trading
and you know question i've gotten
recently is you know canopy can the
overflow sequencing tool be automated
and yes it can in markers so let me take
you through the setup really quick
now the instructions you can find them
in the description below
and it's just very easy steps obviously
open a new chart or use your existing
one you're going to turn on the chart
trader choose your atm add order flow
sequencing if it's not already there
you're going to add
markers plus the force you're going to
add
two copies of markers copy one for the
buy one for the cells then you got to go
in and
set up the buy and sell copies
so go into markers plus and change first
the working mode to auto enable longs
enable shorts enable fast signal modes
because you're going to use fast signals
you can change the name
of the fast signals name to longs for
buys and
the shorts to shorts so you can you can
change it to whatever you want i like to
use long as in shorts you could use buys
and sells whatever you like it's up to
you
and the money management you may depend
on the market you're trading in this
example and we're showing you ultra
bonds
and ultra bonds is 31.25 a tick and if
you're trading micros
you probably keep it at 500 but for
ultra bonds you know you gotta you gotta
make it wider because based on your stop
and you take profit you know on ultra
bonds i use a stop of uh five ticks
so
i'm changing it again to 5000 up and
down for
max daily profit max daily loss again
you can set it to a thousand if you want
or 750 it's up to you
and then let's set up the individual
markers copy first to buy
go in and change the markers variable
name to longs enable fast signal
go to data series and add the order flow
sequencing
with the settings that you use
the settings that you use
you know you have to set them for both
the buys and the cells
change the parameters plot for the
normal buy signal then you got to change
the setup how it's calculated to on each
tick from on bar close and then the
plots i like to keep it the same as the
actual indicator which is blue triangle
up eight
and same thing for the cells
only this time you're doing for this the
shorts so you gotta change the name to
shorts
enable fast signal data series all right
you gotta set up the order flow
sequencing with the same settings that
you use for your buys
but this time you're going to change the
from normal buy signals to normal sell
signal
then you're going to calculate change
that from on bar close to on each tick
and change the plots red triangle down
8. okay now a few last minute checks
before trading make sure the atm is
selected you turn on auto mode and you
make sure the correct account is showing
all right so let's take a look at a
chart here
okay so here i have my
normal chart so first thing you're going
to do add chart trader if you don't
already have it on click apply so it'll
show up here
and then i'm going to go in and add the
indicator and the markers
indicator so first go here we'll add the
sequencing
i'll change it to the settings that i
like which is three and zero and keep
the trade entry signal on
go to the indicator store folder markers
plus the force since i'm using markers
copy you gotta add two two instances of
it one for the buys one for the cells
okay so first we'll set up markers of
force
um
the
this one here the the time and force
you could keep it as gtc just make sure
at the end of the day all your orders
are cancelled or just change it today
working mode change to auto enable longs
enable shorts fast signal mode okay so
you can see the names here so for
long trades i'm going to change it to
longs for buys
and for cells i'm going to change it to
shorts okay
and this is in here we could change the
max daily loss again if you're trading
micros if i just keep it at 500 it's
fine but i'm using ultra bonds
so
it's a bit uh
more risk involved okay so for now i'm
going to markers copy so i'm going to
set up the longs the buy signals right i
call them longs enable fast signal
change the setup
to calculate on each tick
and the plots
blue solid
triangle up
eight
now the most important step here you got
to go into the data series okay and you
got to add the indicator in here so go
inside open it up sequencing use the
same setup same settings that you want
to use three no look back this is the
buy signal so i'll keep it on buy
okay click ok that's the buy
now the cells
same thing but this time it's the cells
so i want to enable fast signal
remember i call the cells shorts
on each tick
um change the color here from blue to
red because these are my cells all right
um instead of dot i'm going to use
triangle down
eight
and then the most important part here
the data series okay so open that up go
to
the indicators
sequencing three turn that off
change the plot right because now i'm
not plotting the buy signals i'm looking
at the cell signals click
okay ok now it's all set up so just
click apply
okay
click ok
i see here ultrabonds right so last
minute checks make sure it's on auto the
accounts have to match up all right this
one says playback this one says sim
i'm using the playback account because
i'm showing it to you after the market's
closed
so change that make sure that this
matches this right the account up here
matches the account here and choose your
atm right click on there ultra bonds
right make sure that this matches this
so you just click on here and it'll sync
with what's there
all right so i'm in the playback mode um
let me just start it up here
uh okay it's showing me over the weekend
here let me just speed it up
okay let me pause this video while this
catches up
here okay here so it's coming up on the
five o'clock reopen let me just
get a little bit closer here to the
opening time
all right so i'm going to show you the
whole trading day i guess um of this is
starting from the sunday night
uh reopen
okay so here's the first trade
okay so you can see here when it hits
the
when it hits the profit it's at 218
because it's a uh in this in this
example it's a seven tick take profit
and a five tick stop
um
well
let me speed it up here
but i'll just run through the whole day
so you can see
how it was
rather than just show one trade
now of course you know every day is not
going to be as
a great day some days might be a little
bit lesser some days might have a loss
but i just want you to see all the
different
um trades for this day
using this stop and take profit again
it's depending on the market that you're
trading you know you're going to have a
different
risk
atm than what i'm using right if you're
trading obviously if you're trading
micros or e-minis
you're going to have a different atm
strategy
okay so there that it was a loss there
was
there was a trade it took here right
then it got reversed out and then so it
took us small loss
all right now it's you know there's
another loss let's stop at 342.
all right another stop got triggered
all right so now i'm on at -156
so you see it's updating here
all right minus 218.
you know the thing is when when you're
trading
auto
you know using an auto trader you really
have to have your stop and take profit
dialed in
because
you know there's going to be days where
you know it seems like nothing
can go wrong right every trade is is a
winner
there's going to be days where it's just
it doesn't quite go to your take profit
maybe it goes 70 of the way there
you know then then comes in and stops
you out me personally i like to use
markers
to get me into the trade and then i can
manage it from there
you know i i could do the trade
management by watching the order flow
myself
so you can see here there was a bunch of
trades that went through you know so i'm
down to 156 earlier i was up like 400
bucks right now it's at what plus 218
plus 400.
so it's getting here what time is it 10
o'clock in the morning
look at that that's a thousand already
there's a nice move here sell sell sell
see there's some nice again
depending on the market you know the one
nice thing about you know the tool like
markers is you know you can sort of run
it through you know the different um
atm
that you want to try
well here it's coming up on the
close of the day already
two o'clock
okay so there's one last trade here
so here's three o'clock
okay so there four o'clock
so that's all there is to it to set it
up um
you know
pretty nice day
hundred bucks on a one lot but again you
know i i don't want you going out
thinking that you know every day is
going to be this fantastic um you know
friday was also had some nice
price movements you know ultra bonds is
a great contract but there's there's
more to the markets out there than just
e-minis and mnq
um you know there's there's a lot of
great contracts for trading
so hopefully you found this video
helpful if you haven't yet got the um
order flows sequencing tool you just go
to
orderflows.com
sequencing index.html it's kind of a
mouthful the link is in the description
below so have a great night everybody
bye-bye